Republican Senator Marco Rubio's with us
from the Capitol senator good morning
good morning Charlie you have said that
you support this policy my question is
where does it go from here and what are
the risk well that's a great question
it's an important one I think ultimately
I hope that the comment has arrived were
under the White House and the
administration and I believe this is the
case realize that as long as Bashar al
Assad is there you're gonna have Isis or
you're gonna have our nutri or some
other radical element because it's very
presence and after the crimes he's
committed against his own people there
will always be a radical element
fighting against him until he is removed
from power and what are the risks well I
think the risks are an escalation we
don't know what the Russians are going
to do in response it's so far it seems
pretty measured but I certainly think
that if there's an effort to remove
Assad they're going to get a little bit
more aggressive how would you remove him
well first of all the only he has to be
removed through a combination of
alternatives on the ground that are
Syrians not foreign fighters not foreign
forces and again this reminds me of one
of those cage matches and professional
wrestling where you have you know 18
different people in the ring and
sometimes they fight each other and two
of them turn on somebody else
you've got Hezbollah you've got Iran
you've got obviously the Syrian forces
you've got the Russians you've got
multiple rebel groups that are not
jihadist then you have al-nusra and
there was just an al Qaeda group and
their affiliates and then you have Isis
of course so ultimately I think you've
got to have a Sunni which is the
majority in Syria a Sunni non jihadist
alternative which is what we should have
done back in 2011 and I hope now the
work will begin to carve out a space for
them to be able to grow and get more
powerful so they can be a clear
alternative to Assad and whatever
happens hopefully a political
negotiation not continued bloodshed
senator the Syrian president has killed
nearly 500,000 of his own people
five million Syrians have fled as
refugees he's gassed his own people
including children is bombing an
airfield enough well in terms of
retribution or punishment for what he
done of course not he's a war criminal
and he should be brought into
international justice are you concerned
now senator about a retaliatory strike
of any kind from Syria Syria Russia yeah
well first of all the Syrians
have the capacity to retaliate against
the United States other than perhaps
doing asymmetrical things or a chemical
attack which is one of the things that
we need to talk about is different from
the past you do now have hundreds of
American troops as advisors on the
ground helping to lead the fight against
Isis
if Assad is willing to use sarin gas
against his own people civilians he's
probably willing to use those against
Americans and I think he thought he
could get away with it well that's a
good question
I think number one this is about regime
survival and so they feel like they're
losing territory as they were that it's
critical to their survival he's prepared
to go all the way he's got nowhere else
to go for him it's a life-or-death
situation and the other I think I would
say and I said this the other day I do
believe that when the sentiment is out
there that somehow we have given up on
efforts to remove him and that in fact
he's going to stay I do think it gave
him license or perhaps an incentive to
believe he could get away with something
like this yes I'm glad to see that
that's changed you think specifically
the comments by Secretary of State
Tillerson gave him license well again
item I'm not saying that's what
Secretary Tillerson said it I am saying
that I do believe that it's not
coincidental that it's not coincidental
that he was that he sees these
statements out there and within a couple
of days he takes action the important
point is that's not what they're saying
anymore and not just not what they're
saying it's not what they're doing they
made it very clear last night and I will
say this you know I know where the
president was on the campaign on these
issues but I don't think you could watch
that press conference a couple days ago
where he was standing next to the king
of Jordan and not see that he was
personally moved by the images and the
news he got there's a difference between
being a candidate and being the
president and having access to this
information and the gravity of the
office on your shoulders and both last
night in his statements and the day
before in that press conference I think
you saw a person a human being that our
president Donald Trump who was deeply
impacted as we all were yes I'm so much
senator pleasure to have you next
morning